des coups droits des amorties des
matches à enjeu le 28e open de tennis
d'elancourt a tenu toutes ses promesses
organisé depuis le 9 avril dernier au
parc des sports guy boniface l'événement
a attiré plus de 370 t il se mêle venus
d'île de france mais également du nord
de la france
c'est un tour dans la première catégorie
à 2400 euros de lots donc par exemple
vainqueur messieurs gagne 700 euros
voilà donc il ya quand même à l'enjeu
financier l'argent à gagner les finales
étaient programmées ce samedi chez les
dames candice paillat de noisy le roi
s'est incliné contre elodie buisson de
blois après un match accroché le score
4-6 7-6 6-4
elle a très bien vu sur les balles de
match et je me suis tendu parce que
comme j'ai vu que je finissais pas je me
suis détendu dans les moments tendus et
ben je jouais plus court donc j'avais
c'est plus vrai que le match est donc
après elle en a profité
et c'est vrai qu'elle a quatre balles de
match après je les les joues jeux les
jouets bon j'ai un petit peu de chance
la chance de mon côté après c'est vrai
que voilà le match peut très bien être
en sa faveur et elle mérite tout au tout
autant que moi donc là dessus là dessus
voilà c'est je m'en sors mais je m'en
sors
en allant un peu au culot comme on dit
chez les hommes rudy coco originaire de
beaune favori du tournoi remporté
l'épreuve pour la troisième année
consécutive le tennisman s'est imposé en
deux sets 6-1 7-6 contre éric forbach du
tc plaisir